the kardashian jenner fam is gearing up
for their tv comeback kim kardashian
posted on instagram that filming has
started on the family's new hulu show
it's so exciting on thursday the
40-year-old reality star shared a photo
to her instagram story showing a
microphone pack on her lap kim captioned
the photo day one indicating that
production has just begun so we'll just
have to wait and see
kim also shared a screenshot from their
family group text while it's unclear if
it's directly related to the start of
filming it seems kim appreciated the
inspiring message shared by her mom kris
jenner it makes me proud the start of
filming comes just a few months after
the family's long-running reality show
keeping up with the kardashians came to
an end after 20 seasons
shortly after it was announced that the
e-series was ending the kardashian
jenner fam revealed they signed on to a
new lucrative deal with disney that will
bring them back to our tv screens
chris and her daughters kim chloe and
kourtney kardashian and kendall and
kylie jenner are set to star and
executive produce this new reality
series for hulu in the us and star
everywhere else isn't that crazy details
are limited about the show but the
content is expected to debut in late
2021. tune in because you never know
what's going to happen something else
you can expect seeing courtney and her
boyfriend travis barker together a
source told e.t back in june that the
blink 182 drummer is set to appear on
the hulu show and his kids might pop up
too but not as much as he will be
featured i love it it's a topic kim
recently opened up about while speaking
with ellen degeneres is travis going to
be a part of this does he want to be in
this
i i honestly haven't talked to him about
it but i'm assuming because he's such a
big part of courtney's life that
hopefully they will be on i love their
relationship like they've
grown so much together and have really
like made some amazing um just i mean to
think that they've been neighbors and
friends for almost 15 years neighbors
for like a decade and then all of a
sudden
they cannot keep their hands off of each
other the skim's founder also talked
about how excited she is to get back to
filming with her family and seeing her
sister's new relationship play out i
will say this is the longest we haven't
filmed for this has been like months
like over six months maybe eight months
ten months and it's crazy how since
we've had this free time all of the
stuff that's gone on whether it's like
you know this relationship or courtney's
relationship or whoever's it's like
people have had this like free time off
and
had these beautiful
new relationships blossom and it's gonna
be really fun and interesting to see
filming dynamics and us back together
and i'm excited
you